ladies and gentlemen i'm delighted to be
talking to you today
at the kickoff of the eu's sustainable
energy week
there could of course be no better time
for our meeting
in only a couple of days cop26 will
start the un climate conference will be
a moment of truth
because current commitments are not
enough to keep the world on track to
reach the goal that we all agreed upon
in paris limiting global warming to 1.5
degrees
above pre-industrial levels
most of you have been working in this
field for many years so you know better
than anyone that we have to be even more
ambitious
and i can assure you
the european union will do everything
to make cop26 a success
because our climate cannot wait and this
is why europe is committed
to becoming the first climate neutral
continent by 2050
and with the european green deal we have
proposed the world's most advanced
blueprint
to reduce emissions
we will put a price on pollution
and we will make sure
that the energy we use is clean
indeed the energy transition is at the
heart of our european green deal
today our energy system alone is
responsible for 75
of the eu's greenhouse gas emissions
so we need to decarbonize europe's
energy mix
and the good news is we are on track to
achieve this
in 2020 for example renewable power
generation overtook fossil fuels in the
european union
and european industry
is a global leader in this sector
particularly in offshore wind
we want to build on this achievement and
further speed up the use of renewables
in europe and this is why
for 2030
we propose to raise our renewable target
to 40 percent of our energy
we also need to use energy more
efficiently and here too we will propose
targets to reflect our ambition
because only what gets measured gets
done
i know that such fundamental transitions
are not easy
and i'm well aware of the challenges
that some of your industries are facing
but i am more than confident
that with our european green deal
we will turn our fight against the
climate crisis
into an economic opportunity for all
thanks to the european green deal and
the innovations that come with it
european businesses are best place
to offer climate solution for markets
not only in the european union but
across the globe
so let me give you two examples which i
find especially inspiring in the context
of this european sustainable energy week
the first is hydrogen
clean hydrogen is a perfect way
to help reach our goal of climate
neutrality
it will help to clean up some of our
most polluting industries
steel aluminum and heavy goods transport
and this is why by 2030 already
we aim to increase annual production of
green hydrogen to 10 million tons
it is high time to move hydrogen
technologies
from laboratories to factory floors and
into people's everyday lives
the green highland project for example
on the island of mallorca is a great
example
it is the first hydrogen valley on an
european island
it will generate distribute and use at
least 300 tonnes of renewable hydrogen
every year
produced from solar energy on majorca
green hydrogen will fuel
a fleet of fuel cell buses and rental
vehicles on the island
it will generate heating for commercial
and public buildings
and it will supply auxiliary power for
ferries and port operations
this is our european green deal at work
for european citizens
or take clear x for instance
a project whose forerunner won our
sustainable energy weeks engagement
award
in 2020
and this is my second example
clear x will help 38 000 consumers in
eastern and southern europe
to invest in
and install renewable energy
in systems like photovoltaic
panels batteries
pallet stoves or heat pumps
and with projects like this we are
enabling people everywhere
to reap the benefits of the energy
transition
decarbonizing the way we produce energy
not only helps our planet
it also provides benefits on other
fronts
we have all seen in recent weeks how
crucial it is
to reduce our dependency on fossil fuels
such as gas oil and coal
currently we're facing a steep global
rise in energy prices which is basically
a rise in gas prices
that has happened before especially when
economies are picking up
and supply lags behind demand
but europe is currently importing 97
of its oil
44 of its coal and
90 of its gas
this makes our economy extremely
vulnerable to price fluctuations in
global energy markets and it makes us
dependent
by contrast
the production costs of renewable energy
have remained stable in fact they've
even decreased in recent years
so there can be only one conclusion
we must speed up the move from fossil
fuels to renewable energy
every kilowatt of electricity produced
with renewable energy
is not only an insurance against rising
energy prices
it also helps us to reduce our
dependency on imports
making both our society
and our economy more resilient and our
planet a healthier place
ladies and gentlemen the european green
deal is europe's calling card on the
world stage
and in glasgow we will continue to reach
out to all countries
to convince them to be much more
ambitious too
following the example of the european
union
most of the major economies have set
targets for climate neutrality by 2050
or shortly after
from the united states to china
we now need to hear
concrete plans
to keep within reach the limiting of
global warming to 1.5 degrees
and we need to support the least
developed and most vulnerable countries
the major economies
have a special duty to help them adapt
to climate change and reduce their
missions as well
we should help these countries to
leapfrog
beyond the fossil fuel-based economic
development
an important tool for this
is climate finance
europe is already the leading
contributor to the global goal of 100
billion dollars per year
and on top of the 25 billion dollars
that we currently provide
i have pledged for the european union a
top-up of 5 billion dollars until 2027.
i look to all developed countries
to join us in closing the climate
finance gap
this is an important condition for
success of cop 26.
every country has a responsibility
and the time to act
is now
thank you